because i have a few extra minutes with
you uh i i like asking uh like a
curveball at the beginning uh i love the
movie it's not hard-hitting i promise i
love the movie cloud atlas just love
and i wanted to know if you could share
um what it was like working with the
wachowskis on that and if that film
holds a special place in your heart
it definitely holds a special place i
mean i knew when i got asked to do that
movie i would never in my career get to
play in a movie and play five characters
just would never happen so i knew that
that was a film worth fighting for i
love the wachowskis i love
the largeness of their imagination i
love um the world that they created the
subject matter of the piece you know i
think
not everybody
uh
got it
you know not everybody um it wasn't
everybody's cup of tea but it was
certainly mine
and um
and everybody that worked on it i think
we were all thrilled to be a part of
something that we knew would probably
never happen again
uh absolutely uh the film's a
masterpiece so f all the people that
don't like it whatever um
oh it's it's fantastic um so i'm i'm
curious you obviously made john wick
three prior to doing bruised how did
actually training for that role maybe
help you in terms of of preparing you
know playing this role
well i knew when i was training for john
wick i knew that bruce was coming so i
knew that it would be a three-year
period of just training so i had to you
know what i had to learn for john wick
really had nothing to do with what i had
to uh
do for bruised but what it did do was it
got me into the cycle of training and
working hard and spending three four
sometimes five hours a day in the gym it
you know i learned about the importance
of recovery and having the proper diet
and
you know i i understood what the next
three years of my life would be like and
so training for john wick got me totally
prepared for that
on what day of the shoot i mean this is
such an ambitious project for your
directorial debut on what day of the
shoot were you like maybe i should have
just done a romantic comedy
never
never i never had that thought thank and
i couldn't afford to have that thought i
had to keep believing that i was meant
to do this
this was my passion and nobody was going
to deny me and i was going to keep
putting one foot in front of the other
and that i was going to see this through
yeah i keep telling myself that
obviously i'm just joking around with
that but
you know what i mean but like i'm i am
curious as a director um
the editing process is ultimately where
this all comes together and when you're
and where you're crafting these fight
scenes and it's you know it's the movie
um so maybe what what surprised you when
you got in the editing room uh you know
that maybe you weren't expecting
well i can't say there were any things i
didn't expect because after working with
chad what i learned was that
the more and this is how he operates in
john wick like piano does all of his own
stunts all the performers that come into
the world of wic they perform their own
stunts and what that does for the
director is it frees you up to put the
camera any place you want to put the
camera because you have nothing to hide
you're not hiding a stunt woman you're
not hiding something that you don't want
the audience to see
so luckily for me because i'd come from
the school of chad i and i performed all
of my own stunts and i had the flyweight
champion of the world i'm fighting with
i didn't have anything to hide in the
edit i could put it together the way i
wanted to put it together because we we
did it ourselves
did you end up having like a i'm i like
talking about editing did you end up
having having a much longer cut um or
you know what i mean
my first cut was almost four hours
like every director because every moment
was so important to me the fight was
like a real fight like
we shot because each round valentina and
i really shot five rounds i mean five
minutes per round so i had a real
ufc length fight on my hands and so the
first edit i put it all in there because
we work so hard and so little by little
we started to have to chop things down
and we had to shape a story that was
palpable but as a first-time director
and i think every director you put your
whole thing together the way you saw it
in your head and then you realize that's
a bit indulgent and nobody's going to
sit and watch that and you need to start
you know
crafting a different story from from
what you may have
originally intended
did you what was um what was like the
length where you're like you have a
director's cut and you're like i don't
know how i'm gonna get this any shorter
was it like two and a half hour you know
what i mean yeah it was probably at the
two and a half hour mark i really
thought i was done and for me i'd cut so
much out of it that i thought i can't
lose another thing it's going to change
my whole story it's going to change i'm
fighting for the integrity of these
characters and this fight has to be this
fight and
it was little by little netflix kept
saying to me
keep trying keep keep keep trying keep
so i would go back and i would chip away
and chip away and sometimes my editor
would i would say terry i can't chip
away anymore you just have to go
and show me something because i love all
of this too much i love all of these
characters so she would come and she
would have a pass at it
um
and then i would have a nervous
breakdown and then i would come back
around and say okay
what parts of what you just did were
good and what parts do we have to put
back in because i just can't live
without and so it was a constant dance
to get down to what netflix wanted me to
get to was about a two-hour film
totally um i love learning about the
behind the scenes the making of movies
um what do you think soon-to-be fans of
this film would be surprised to learn
about the making of it
that i'm going to put a behind bruised
making of the movie out for them to see
and they're going to see
everything
about it and i think they'll be shocked
to learn how hard it was for me to not
only get the money but to keep the money
how hard we all worked all the obstacles
that we faced i faced on a daily basis
but they'll also see the fun and they'll
see the the love and the camaraderie but
they're going to see it they're going to
see it all
is it going to be on netflix the behind
the scenes
i'm still negotiating where it's going
to be so it'll be eventually live on
netflix as i think a sister project to
this movie like a like a sister piece
but where it's gonna air first i'm still
i'm still in negotiations with where
it's gonna actually air first
that's all the time i have thank you so
much congratulations i hope you're
making another movie again soon thank
you